[Music]
all right guys
do you believe in magic genies oh yeah
you do
i do like them i believe in the evil
mischievous kind of what's that kind
they don't ever they take your wish too
literally and then they ruin your life
oh yeah you got to be like all specific
they troll you oh
you're you're like i wish everything i
touched turned to gold
and then and then you touched your wife
you're like oh no then goes you wanted
it and i'm like oh she's kind of hot
covered in gold that's kind of cool
it sounds like a goosebumps episode be
careful what you
wish for yeah there's rules to genies
there's like you can't we can't wish for
love you can't wish for
all genies you can't wish for more
wishes right you can't wish for more
wishes cause that's the loophole i
always wanted to wish to bring somebody
back from the dead too oh yeah
how come you can't wish for love is it
because you can't you can't force
someone else's will
yeah but what what if i wish to make
a person that doesn't exist oh
you know or that too um like make a new
person and then that new person loves me
can you do that oh like invent a pros
that is the saddest wish ever it'll
probably not
i'll have a person forever what like
what if joe
dies and then the genie comes and is
like
you can't bring him back and like what
if you made a replica
just a replica you wouldn't change
anything have you seen
not while he's here steve it's the
beginning of the relationship i love
every pet cemetery stephen king one wait
is it like a frankenstein but then the
dog it's like their cat dies
and then like there's a i don't want to
bring him back like no
it's a different version but they're
evil
part of the deal they were evil well
they didn't know listen we don't have to
write these wishes out so genie if
you're watching this right now give me
some time
if i die you could immediately [ __ ]
because i want you to be happy
can i cremate you and then keep you want
to lock it yep okay so what's up with
this genies
so a doctor allegedly
paid 335 thousand dollars
for a magical lamp capable of granting
him
saw this it looked like aladdin's lamp
like a really [ __ ] version i'll show you
a picture
he's so stressed out like a real md type
doctor
yeah dude probably rona's happening he's
like man
that looks pretty [ __ ] legit though
he's like 300 grand to save the world
and then he's like rubbing it and it's
nothing's coming out and like
technically
on some sites uh there was different
articles written and on some sites they
said he only paid
a down payment of forty one thousand
dollars only it's small down payment
affordable you realized it was
fake can i just say it looks actually
pretty simple it looks pretty sick right
is it made out of gold though
it's like gold foil i don't know what
it's made out of it doesn't say
legit i would buy that do you really
think the genie is going to come out of
it
if you rub it hard enough me personally
yeah so there was this doctor i want it
to happen
okay but just to be real can i just
really quickly ask you all would you you
would rub it though wouldn't you
oh but not make it obvious you know like
oh whoops i slipped oh
no like i think this is dumb by the way
like let me just clean this spot off
like come on does this really work like
haha
who would ever think this would work oh
my goodness i'm gonna rub it for reals
like a bowling ball yeah don't you have
this bar's going in with this rag
like magical g yeah you have to say
something while you rub it right
oh do you uh i don't think special chant
uh there isn't in this particular case
although there might have i don't know
it doesn't say cause didn't aladdin from
historical literature he just picked up
the
store he just picked it up and was like
oh the lamb he's like what the [ __ ]
oh yeah in the disney version he got
trapped inside of a
like a whole an underground area that's
a disney version
that's the that's the lying one it's not
the historical one okay
sorry um so this doctor
he performed a surgery on a woman oh
[ __ ] he
yeah that's not the crazy part bart if
you can imagine
okay so then after the surgery he wanted
to keep checking up on her
he was doing visits to redress her
wounds to change out her wounds
her bandages or whatever um and while he
was there one time
there were some tantrics i don't really
know what oh [ __ ] hand tricks that
sounds sexy i probably should look that
up is it like
sex religious sexual people used to be
they were there are self-described
tantrics they boast about magical powers
so people um they're two people yes
can't tricks are
people they're two guys in this
situation i believe it's about
energy it's like a it's like an energy
dance between two people okay i didn't
know
tantric yeah was a person yeah i think
that's like a mystic it's like uh yeah
exactly it's like a
shaman like but it's tantric but it's
about it's about like being close
not the sex version that although that
exists too but it's about being close to
somebody in in exchange
for that there's two dudes on the verge
of coming at any time well there are two
dudes but
can you imagine they walk around jacking
each other off the whole time and
they're all edging
yeah it's like they can't be very
tangible i can't imagine that
um so there is a there's a guy his name
is isla muden
and he's a tantric and he introduced the
doctor to his partner
anise and the two offered to sell him a
real life
wish granting aladdin lamp two con
artists that is not even their names
that's bob's doctor was like they were
pretty convincing okay
so on the one occasion they like rubbed
the lamp and they used the special
perfumes that made it seem very real
that this like ge was coming out
and he actually saw a genie that
promised to make him a billionaire what
yeah but then how did they meet him
dressed as the prince on top of an
elephant no wait was
was the genie wearing like a two-piece
kind of like pink look
no this is where it gets funnier okay so
but these two
tantrics are with the lady that he did
surgery on that he's checking okay this
[ __ ]
is [ __ ] weird oh yeah so he starts
he's like okay
this is legit and he starts paying some
money
he puts some payments in how did they
convince a genie came out like wait hold
on it's like
because an actual genie came out they
connected to the lady who had surgery
and is she still on the bed like her
[ __ ] all out
he dressed the wounds first oh okay okay
and then i was like these two magical
men
showed up i just needed they're helping
her with her magic stuff
and then they were like hey you want in
on this magic stuff okay so then
by the way you want some tuna yeah he
makes a few payments and then he's like
yo hey i've been making these payments
can i take the lamp home now like can i
bring it home and they were like no no
it doesn't work that way you gotta
finish paying that's why you can't come
out and then you can yeah when i go and
get crystal ball readings i don't ask
for the ball to come with me home
yeah no but he's paying for this lamp
and so yeah
and he wants the genie at home right
it's 335 000
so after the third or fourth time of
them being like you can't take the lamp
it won't work at your house
he was like i think something fishy is
going on so he reported them too
for the fourth time i believe you
reported them to the cops the fourth
time
and the cops found out that basically it
was one of the guys
is lamudin dressed up as a jean oh my
god
he didn't even write them the same guy
it's like it's like when superman puts
on his glasses and they're like who are
you
and he's a doctor he's a doctor he just
goes to show
that just because you have a degree does
not mean you know what you were doing
wait the doctor said i'm sure he's a
good doctor i mean
clearly because the patient that he was
worried about is now seeking
out shaman they were were they was she
in on it yeah so it turns out
she's the wife of the other guy wait so
it is
this woman because i was about to say
something else so this woman went and
got
surgery too yeah sucker him in i don't
know
if the surgery was legit like if she
actually needed it or what
but like she did get a surgery done but
she had they have
done similar cons to several other
families
so could you just imagine like babe okay
so i'm gonna need to stab you right now
just gonna stab you it's gonna be a
quick surgery he'll come back
don't worry for 300 grand oh i heard i
heard this guy believes in genies
just just say your panic shirts i want
to see how the performance went down
right like it was like
here's the genie and then he comes out
in his blue outfit
i am the genie but what did he did he
only
wish for a billion dollars or it like
did it like prophesies
did the genie come out and say you're
gonna be a billionaire
was he doing stick was it work in the
room at least did the blue look like
will smith or did it look like big fat
liar it didn't enough
he did they did a good enough job that
the doctor was like damn this was legit
i thought it wasn't before but now i
know it's legit
or did he look like do you look like
sinbad when he was a genie man sinbad
was never a joke that was a test
what country was this i don't think i'm
ever going to go this country this was
in india
in india it was never sinbad right it
was someone else it was like uh
was it shaq okay shazam yeah but people
think
sinbad was the genie yeah the girl is
still on the loose
uh oh so she done left her man she
wished her way up
she's got the genie okay you have one
wish
what is it oh and it can't be a part of
the three like the three
yeah one wish and i don't have to
amazing health till death
that's really good so how do you die
then well
i wanna i mean i hope a lot of ways you
can die without what natural causes
i hope you when i die in my sleep in in
my 90s and i have great health all the
way to the end
yeah just but then i want to be able to
eat shitty foods
and still be healthy two wishes now [ __ ]
okay i'll i'll just i just i just want
to go no i think that could like mesh
into one because you're going to have
good health until you die yes
no matter what you want no matter what
smart okay go nikki okay
oh me i have to say too i'll go we all
have to good health for everyone
until then oh [ __ ] you what if the
caveat is
everyone but you who would you sacrifice
that
do you want to die a legend you get you
get kidney stones every year
everyone's problem no that's the claws
but everyone
is cured of corona and there's no more
and then you take all of their all of
your friends why is the genie so mean
this worldwide
that's why i hate genies no i wouldn't
do it [ __ ] that i need to live [ __ ]
my [ __ ] crypto's mooning i need to i
need to be alive for this [ __ ]
to the moon yeah i also would pick a
selfish wish [ __ ] y'all yeah
i would have eminem give me a private
concert oh [ __ ] private just look on
steve's face when she
he's like that's what you're gonna use
your [ __ ] wish stage
and that's it it's a concert code for
something else
fine no i just want a concert one wish
and that's what you're gonna waste it on
you that's what i wish she not know that
she can make money and make that happen
no i can make my own money girl no but
i'm saying no i shouldn't make money and
make it you can buy them for a birthday
i mean you're gonna wish for money
you're wasting a wish you don't know if
you would be bought
like that you make enough money you can
definitely do like eminem here's a
billion dollars he just wants to do it
for me
i don't know i don't have to pay him to
want to do it
and you don't have to ask more exactly
eminem is three years from being a
[ __ ] forward
i don't care you know it i don't care
i just want it you want him to want to
perform there's a malaysian prince out
there that already had him for his debut
or something i don't
care joe and eminem showed him his butt
too
yup i don't want to see his butt that's
great or whatever he's just like sure
do you think it's bleached like his hair
yeah i do it's not bleached anymore he's
brunette now what do you want nelson
i would get the i would ask for the
trillion dollars and then find eminem
and i'd be like you know that one weird
girl that you had to know where you
performed a concert for
and you didn't know why do it one more
time here's a billion dollars
i got two concerts
generous act i would be like he has a
trillion dollars and he only gave a
billion for that
like are you serious that's like giving
away a dollar it's nothing
and that'd be like hey steve look at
this other billion i burned it i didn't
give it to you
i'm like he has a billion dollars he
couldn't he could have just given it
world hunger but he did a spike i have
another one here you go word hunger
don't feed steve though everyone else oh
he has kidney stones every year for all
your good health what would you do
i have no idea i want to hear bart first
i feel like his would be interesting
i don't know how these wishes work
he's like i work for my [ __ ] i don't
wish every birthday he goes
no so for mine would be like an
unlimited supply of toothpaste
any time someone has a single negative
thought about me they [ __ ] themselves
yeah remember someone has to write
something like a
a bad comment or anything they crap
their pants are they trying to cancel me
they just start [ __ ] themselves oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
explosive diarrhea that can they can can
that be yeah i think so i think that'd
be
tough that's a pretty epic way i'm
invincible the minute anyone wants to
write anything or say anything they just
start [ __ ] them you're gonna find
some ugly truths every single
one of your friends just like [ __ ]
every time you see them oh my god
ah [ __ ] bart's here again cut to outside
bart's house in his own house
it gets filled up with [ __ ] and the door
bursts off its hinges
taika is running around but you too
he takes off like a rocket and starts
hitting cabinets in the kitchen dude
like we just potty trained you what
happened and he's like because i hate
you
dad wait wait wait i don't think there's
no topping that
you don't have any wishes i don't have a
[ __ ] clue
so indecisive i'd make a wish now and
then change it tomorrow oh you can't do
that i know
but i think that not knowing is better
than asking for
that
eminem
[Music]